AASTHA BHARDWAJ: Welcome,
my name is Aastha.
And I'm an engineer
on the Cloud SQL team.
In this video, I'll show you
how to create, run, and manage
SQL instances using
Google Cloud SQL.
Cloud SQL helps manage
mundane administrative tasks
for MySQL and
Postgres databases.
So you can focus
on what matters.
Let's walk through how
to create a Postgres
database on Cloud SQL and
connect to it from the Google
Cloud Shell.
You can set up an instance
in just a few steps.
We'll start with the basics.
And I'll point out some options
for additional configuration
along the way.
We'll start by navigating to
Cloud SQL, in the GCP console,
and clicking Create Instance.
We'll select Postgres
and press Next.
We'll give the instance a name.
And let's not forget to set
the password for our default
account.
This instance will
be created in the US.
And we'll leave
the zone set to Any
so Cloud SQL can choose for us.
Let's take a look at the
configuration options.
You can specify Instant Size,
High Availability, and more.
For this demo, I'll
choose four CPU cores
and then maximize the memory.
Maximizing memory is a
good choice for Postgres,
because it can take
advantage of the extra memory
for performance.
That said, don't worry too
much about initial sizing.
You can scale the
instance up or down later.
Let's increase the storage
capacity to 200 gigabytes,
because increasing disk capacity
also increases performance.
Check out the performance
calculator below.
As I add capacity,
my disk performance
increases, which will
allow my database
to process more
operations per second.
And I'll enable
Automatic Storage
Increase so that I
don't accidentally
run out of disk space.
Lastly, let's ensure that the
database will automatically
provide isolation from failures.
We can do that by enabling
the high availability
configuration, which, for
Postgres, will automatically
failover to another zone
in the case of an outage.
Now that we are happy with the
configuration of our instance,
let's kick off the creation.
It may take a few minutes
for your instance to create.
This is a great time to
grab a quick cup of coffee.
You can also check the
status of your instance
by navigating to
your instance list.
Once you see a green check
mark, your instance is ready.
Looks like our instance
has finished creating.
Let's open the Details
page to continue.
There are many ways to
connect to this instance.
Within GCP, for
example, we could
use App Engine, Compute
Engine, or Container Engine,
but we could also connect,
from just about anywhere,
by authorizing IP addresses
or using the Cloud SQL Proxy.
For this demo, I'll connect
using the Google Cloud Shell.
Cloud Shell provides
command line access
to all of your cloud resources,
such as Cloud SQL instances,
directly from the browser.
To open the Cloud Shell, click
Connect Using Cloud Shell.
As you can see, the
relevant gcloud command
to connect to your
Cloud SQL instance
has been pre-typed for us.
So all we need to
do is press Enter,
and then enter our root
password from before,
and now we're connected.
So let's add some data.
I'll create a table, and
we'll insert a few rows.
Finally, I'll make sure the
data is now in our database.
And it is.
Great.
So to recap, in the
last few minutes,
we just created a
Cloud SQL instance,
with high performance
and high availability,
and connected to it
with Cloud Shell.
Now that you've seen how to
get started, give it a try.
You can learn more about Google
Cloud SQL and our free trial
program here.
Thank you for watching.